i think there's a lot of work that needs
to be done
before i can think about being in a
relationship with anybody
matt james is speaking out after his
breakup from rachel curcanell
and weighing in on the idea of a
reconciliation
i need time to process everything that's
going on and
i want to respect rachel and what she's
got to do as well on monday's finale of
the bachelor
viewers watched as matt gave the 24 year
old graphic designer his final rose
but didn't propose i've seen what
rushing into a proposal in marriage
can do in my family and it's ugly
and it's not something i want for you or
for us
that's why i can't propose to you today
and while matt and rachel enjoyed their
love together after filming wrapped
that all came to a screeching halt when
racially insensitive photos of her
surfaced online the most
disappointing thing for me was
having to explain to you why what i saw
was problematic
and why i was so upset the two split and
rachel has since apologized and vowed to
educate herself
after those images of her at a 2018
antebellum old south plantation themed
party emerged
i knew that i had to take a step back
for you to put in that work that you
outlined that you needed to do
and that's something you got to do on
your own
i know that rachel's a good person and
everything that she outlined in her
apology and her statement
i'm looking forward to seeing her do
because i know she's capable of it on
tuesday
matt appeared on good morning america to
reflect on seeing rachel for the first
time since their split
it hit me like a ton of bricks you know
i um
i felt the weight of everything that i
was carrying throughout the season
and with what we were dealing with as a
country
and having to explain that why it was
problematic to me
in our relationship which was extremely
difficult
while matt previously said he was
excited about his future with rachel
he explained that the revelations from
her past
changed everything when you find out
things like i did
that deters you from that ultimate goal
because like i stated during the after
the final rows there's just things that
you might not understand what it means
to be with someone like me
but matt said it all played out like it
was supposed to
i would say that
the conversations that have come from
everything that's taken place
are more important than anything i could
have left with and
if that means that i leave
under the circumstances that i left with
then um
so be it you know and when asked if he
would ever consider dating rachel again
he had this to say i think there's a lot
of work
that needs to be done before i can think
about being in a relationship with
anybody
matt also weighed in on tasia adams and
caitlyn bristow
taking over hosting duties on the
upcoming season of the bachelorette
while chris harrison is on temporary
leave from the show
i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that the longtime bachelor
host came under fire
in february after defending rachel's
past racist behavior
during a conversation with rachel
lindsay the picture was
from 2018 at an old south antebellum
party
rachel is it a good look in 2018 or is
it not a good look in 2021
because there's a big difference for
matt he's excited to see the franchise
mix things up
i'm excited it's a fresh start and we
need more women hosting